we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 davidp
um we have switched
live phone calls from a sort of normal
phone line
to using discord i think that the calls
are much better both in terms of audio
quality and in terms of substance
but this caller doesn't like it he's
almost like
begging me for mercy to stop the calls
altogether take a listen to this
oh my god more
discord calls right
agonizing just make a separate show
if you want to hear from people all
around the world it's horrific
other than that thank you i appreciate
the compliment
yeah listen i mean we've gone through
this before most
people like the calls the people that
don't absolutely hate them we've
packaged them
in the second half of the friday show
the rest of the entire uh week of shows
is not live calls
um and we're we're we are looking at
you know different mechanisms maybe for
screening or different things
i get it i get that it's not for
everybody but we actually do get the
calls that are good
i think are really good and the audio
quality has improved on discord
the substance has improved on discord so
we're going to keep it going for now but
it's very easy to skip it if you don't
like it okay
on the bonus show today we will talk
about democrats blocking a resolution to
censure
maxine waters over her comments
regarding
george floyd derek chovin verdict
protests i think her comments were
misguided
we will talk though about the absurdity
of the censure resolution
uh given what people in the republican
party have said
a u.s senators are looking to ban
private ownership of lions and tigers
this is actually part of a bigger story
which i will talk about
on the bonus show as well and we are
going to talk
about the completely abortive launch
of my pillow ceo mike lindell's social
media platform
it was a disastrous and humiliating
fiasco
which i love it i'm not gonna lie i'm
really enjoying the disaster
of the my pillow um social media
platform
launch all of those stories and
more and i will be joined by producer
pat
on today's bonus show you can get the
bonus show as a member
by signing up at joinpakman.com i
believe
to this day that the normal membership
pricing
is very very reasonable but i am always
glad to offer you a discount you can use
the coupon code
immoral 21 yes immoral the discount is
so low
it's almost immoral immoral 21 all one
word all lowercase
to get a big discount off of membership
and then you will get
instant access to the bonus show and i
will see you then or tomorrow
if you're not a member